This lecture is about the expectation
maximization algorithm, also called the
EM algorithm.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of
probabilistic topic models.
In particular, we're going to introduce
the EM algorithm, which is a family of
useful algorithms for computing the
maximum likelihood estimate of mixture
models.
So this is now familiar scenario of
using a two component mixture model to
try to factor out the background words
from one topic word distribution here.
So we are interested in
computing this estimate.
And we're going to try to adjust these
probability values to maximize the
probability of the observed document,
and know that we assume that all the
other parameters are known.
So the only thing unknown is this
word probabilities are given by theta sub d
update.
And in this lecture were going to look
into how to compute this maximum likelihood
estimator.
Now let's start with the idea of
separating the words in the text data
into two groups.
One group would be explained by the
background model, the other group would
be explained by the Unknown topic word
distribution
After all, this is the basic idea of
mixture model.
But suppose we actually know which word is from which
distribution, so that would mean, for
example these words:
the is and we are known to be from this
background word distribution.
On the other hand, the other words,
text, mining, clustering, etc are known
to be from the topic word distribution.
If you can see the color, then these
are shown in blue.
These blue words are then assumed to be
from the topic word distribution.
If we already know how to separate
these words, then the problem of
estimating the world distribution would
be extremely simple, right?
If you think about this for a moment,
you realize that well we can simply take all
these words that are known to be from
this word distribution theta sub d
and normalize them.
So indeed this problem will be very
easy to solve.
If we had known which words are from
which distribution precisely.
And this is in fact
Making this model no longer mixture
model because we can already observe
which distribution has been used to
generate which part of the data, so we
actually go back to the Single word
distribution problem, and in this case
let's call these words
that are known to be from theta d
pseudo document
d prime and then all we need to do is
just normalize these word counts for
each word w sub I.
And that's fairly straightforward, and
it's just dictated by the maximum likelihood
estimate now.
This idea, however, doesn't work,
because we in practice don't really
know which word is from which
distribution.
But this gives us the idea of perhaps
we can guess which word is from which.
distribution.
Specifically, given all the parameters can we infer the distribution the word is from
So let's assume that we actually know tentative
probabilities for these words in
theta sub D.
So now all the parameters are known for
this mixture model.
And now let's consider word like
text.
So the question is, do you think text
is more likely have been having been
generated from theta sub d or from
theta sub B?
So in other words, we want to infer
which distribution has been used to
generate this text.
Now, this inference process is a
typical Bayesian inference situation
where we have some prior about
These two distributions so can you see
what is our prior here?
Well the prior here is the probability of
each distribution, right?
So the prior is given by these two
probabilities.
In this case the prior is
Saying that each model is equally
likely, but we can imagine perhaps a
different prior possible.
So this is called prior because this
is our guess of which distribution has
been used to generate the world before
we even observe the word.
So that's why we call it prior.
if we don't observe the word or
we don't know what word has been
observed, our best guess is just say
well.
They are equally likely.
Alright, so it's just a flipping a
coin.
Now in Bayesian inference, we typically
then would update our belief after we
have observed evidence.
So what is evidence here?
While the evidence here is the word
text.
Now that we are interested in the word
text, so text can be regarded as
evidence.
And in the if we use Bayes rule to
combine the prior and the data
likelihood, what we will end up with is
to combine the prior with the likelihood
that you see here, which is basically
the probability of the word text from
each distribution and we see that in
both cases text is possible that even
in the background it is still possible.
It just has a very small probability.
So intuitively, what would be your
guess?
So in this case
Now, if you're like many others, you
will guess text is probably from theta sub d
is more likely from  theta sub d,
why? And you will probably see that
it's because.
Text has a much higher probability
here.
By the theta sub d, than by the
background model, which has a very
small probability.
And by this we are going to say text is
more likely from theta sub d.
So you see our guess of which
distribution has been used to generate
the text would depend on how high the
probability of the data the text is in
each word distribution.
We are going do tend to guess the distribution
that gives the word higher probability
and this is likely to maximize the
likelihood right so.
We're going to choose word that has a
higher likelihood.
So in other words, we're going to
compare these two probabilities.
Of the word given by each
distributions.
But our
guess must also be affected by the
prior, so we also need to compare these
two priors why? because imagine if we
adjust these probabilities, we're going
to say the probability of choosing a
background model is almost 100%.
Now if we have that kind of strong
prior, then that would affect your
guess.
You might think well, wait a moment,
maybe text could have been from the
background as well, although the
probability is very small here.
The prior is very high.
So in the end we have to combine the
two and the bayes formula provides
provides us a solid and principled way
of making these kind of guess to quantify
that.
So more specifically, let's think about
the probability that this word text
has been generated.
In fact from theta sub D, The in order
for texture to be generated from theta sub d
two things must happen first.
The theta sub d must have been
selected, so we have the selection
probability here, and Secondly, we also
have to actually have observed text
from the distribution.
So when we multiply the two together,
we get the probability that text has in
fact has been generated from theta sub d
Similarly, for the background model an.
The probability of generating text
is another product of similar form.
We also introduced a latent variable Z
here to denote whether
the word is from the background or
the topic.
When Z is zero, it means it's from the
topic
theta sub d when it's one, it means
it's from the background theta sub b.
So now we have the probability that
text is generated from each.
Then we simply we can simply normalize
them to have estimate of the
probability that the word text is from
theta sub d or from theta sub b.
And equivalently, the probability that
Z is equal to 0 given that the observed
evidence is text.
So this is
Application of Bayes rule.
But this step is very crucial for
understanding the EM algorithm.
Because if we can do this, then we
would be able to 1st initialize the
parameter values
Somewhat randomly, and then we're going
to take a guess of these Z values and or
which distribution has been used to
generate which word and the initialized parameter
values would allow us to have a
complete specification of the mixture
model, which further allows us to apply
Bayes rule to infer which distribution
is more likely to generate
Each word and this prediction
essentially helped us to separate words
from the two distributions, although we
can't separate them for sure, but we
can separate them probabilistically
as shown here.